all right jamie
jamie uh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally
uh
minerva ohio
small town in ohio that's a very small
town in ohio like 4 000 people
well tell me about your childhood
growing up you had mom and dad
my dad
was a uh in a biker gang he was in and
out of prison my whole life
uh which gay
the outlaws the worst ones uh
my mom was a really good woman i mean
she worked two jobs to support me and my
two sisters
my father on the other hand
was the complete opposite
his idea of a good time was to make fun
of me and my sisters in front of his
friend and degrade us or
whatever you know he was really harsh
with us if we got bad grades in school
you know he beat us half to death
for some reason i had
a
very
major love for the guy because he he was
so well respected by his friends and and
other people you know what i mean so
he's your dad
and then
he ended up killing himself when i was
15.
and uh
i took it really hard ran away from home
while i was away
while i ran away from home
my mom how'd you kill her kill himself a
shotgun in the mouth
[Music]
while i was away
my mom ended up
suffering from
severe
head trauma from my father
all the beatings she had taken from my
father
so
she had been my best friend
my entire childhood and whatnot growing
up and then
now she doesn't even know who i am you
know so
that's really hard on me
like i said i i ran away from home
and uh i joined the carnival
started traveling all over the u.s
got into doing drugs
lots of women
ended up having 11 children with 9
different
baby moms
i ended up in chicago for
that's where i was first homeless was in
chicago
uh
i was actually
i started off robbing houses in the
beginning breaking in people's houses
and stealing stuff
i ended up
going to jail for two years for that
decided i didn't like jail too much so
i tried to find a more legal way
to make money you know and
i
basically started panhandling
but in chicago
the drugs are
everywhere
and the police
like
you come in contact with the police so
much in chicago i got put on probation
so
i ended up going back to jail and back
to jail i was spending more time in jail
than out of jail
so
i finally
left chicago
and
that's when i came here to hollywood
and
it's been the same thing here though i
mean i ain't got no trouble with the law
here because i
rarely do anything illegal
uh i mean i i go boost on the days like
if it rains and i can't go out and
panhandle
i'll turn to boosting but that's like a
last-ditch effort for me
you've been away how many years
uh
three
three three years yes sir
uh
i actually when i first got here i had a
job
it's like a a carnival game but you set
it up at events like uh we did tattoo
conventions car shows uh weed
conventions
and it's a scam game basically
it feeds on people's greed
and
i was working that and it was really
good money i mean i was staying at the
labret apartments four thousand dollars
a month
and then
my girlfriend got in a fight with my
boss's wife
i lost that job
i've been on
that's when i've been on the streets
here in la that's been about nine months
and uh
that's pretty much about the gist of it
and your drug is uh
fentanyl
and i
i also i shoot up fentanyl and i also
shoot up speed once in a while you know
like if i don't feel like getting up one
day or something you know
i use speed as an
energizer pretty much i don't like it
because i don't like to stay awake but
sometimes i just
like i'll get sick from not having the
fentanyl you know
when
the dope sickness just makes it to where
i can't even barely get out of bed so
i'll do the
speed to
give me energy to get out of bed and
that that's usually when i'll go
boosting too is like if i'm dope sick
because it's easy money
you know you run in you grab the [ __ ]
come out and you're staying in a tent
now yeah in harley yep
we just got tents
like a month ago we were just
we get yeah benches and or whatever
hallways
you have any friends
yeah you do uh
yeah they're
pretty much on the same boat as me
luckily though
several of them have gotten into that
project room key here
in the
uh the past couple months so
i'm hoping to get into that as well
what's your biggest regret
uh
leaving home
i should have stayed and been there for
my mom
yeah did you finish high school i went
back and got my ged
and the drugs started a few at what age
uh like 16 when i ran away at 15. i had
smoked weed and stuff before that
you know
nothing major but then
when i ran away to the carnival
uh
it was 1996 i was 16 years old in fargo
north dakota
and someone introduced me to cocaine
and
i just loved it from the beginning
so i i was addicted to coke and crack
for
probably eight years
and then
i'd gotten hurt working at the carnival
and uh
i was on pain pills
prescribed pain pills
and i started overtaking them to get
high
and then i had to so i had to start
buying them on the streets
and uh
a buddy of mine was like have you ever
tried heroin i was like no
you sit here try some
and i went from spending 200 a day on
pain pills to
30 or 40 dollars a day
for the the heroin
and i was getting twice as high
and
that's been
17 years or so ago
i've been doing heroin or
some sort of opiate ever since then
do you think your addictive personality
is
handed down from somebody in your family
or i honestly believe so yeah my dad was
a die-hard alcoholic and
he was addicted he shot up crack cocaine
as well
my mom
was addicted to work
but yeah everybody on my dad's side of
the family were drug addicts or
alcoholics
and then my mom's dad and grandpa so her
father's side were alcoholics as well
would you consider yourself
self-destructive
i'm my own worst enemy
i mean
i feel
i have the ability to be better than i
am
i
i settle
i feel
you know and i probably should that
that's probably my biggest regret is
that i settle for less than
what i'm capable of
because i mean i
when i was in school i got
good grades i mean i had straight a's
until my freshman year
i just
i don't know once my dad killed himself
a big part of me died as well and
i quit caring about a lot of stuff
and then like i said my mom lost her
mind and i felt like i didn't have
nobody in the world so yeah what do you
think was going on with your dad that he
committed suicide well i know what was
going on
he was
almost 60 years old and sent to go back
to the penitentiary for 20 years
couldn't deal with it was that
what was it for yeah you killed a woman
yeah having a
dad who's a outlaw biker must
change
the path of your life forever right
yeah i mean i i've seen some things that
nobody should ever see probably
yeah
just
my dad in general i mean
he treated me like crap
but i knew as long as he was around
nobody else could touch me you know what
i mean like
i felt untouchable as long as he was
around me i could say or do whatever i
wanted and i didn't have to worry about
i knew he would take care of it because
he was feared i mean what kind of things
do you see as
a
being
i've seen him beat people half to death
and
drag people behind cars i've seen all
kinds of stuff
just crazy stuff and
this was like eight and nine years old
i was exposed to this stuff
we lived in out in the country like i
said so
they would bring people out to our
it was a little farm we had like 17
acres
they would bring people out there and
torture them and [ __ ] [ __ ]
just
horrible stuff
you've been married before no
you've been loved though
huh you've been in love
yeah absolutely i'm in love right now
with with nine different
you know
with nine different moms to your
children you probably
honestly
i was never there was one of them that i
was in love with my first baby mama and
the other ones
let me tell you like
six of those kids came in the same year
oh really so yeah
that was one one carnival season
i got six different kids in six
different states tell me about the
kearney life
[Laughter]
what are the people that
don't know anything about the carnegie
life not know
i mean
it's a big party i mean
it's
the country's misfits you know
anybody who
can't get a job anywhere else or
you know people that are wanted or
just don't want nobody to know who they
are yeah you know so felons sex
offenders drug addicts
the sex offenders
they're weeding out
uh they're doing a lot of a lot more
background checks and stuff like that
which is good
uh
a lot of times you got to get
fingerprinted and stuff when you go play
a spot
but uh
all they're checking for are sex
offenders and and pedophiles and stuff
like that
uh
but yeah
i've met some of the well before i come
to hollywood i met some of the craziest
people i've ever met
on the carnival
now hollywood
man this place is off the chain
but i think
it's because the crystal meth is so
so widely used here
people are just tweaked out here it's
unbelievable
the other day
i was pokemon hunting on my phone
dude running down hollywood boulevard in
his underwear
screaming that the devil was chasing him
because he found the gates to hell and
these two police officers just turned
and walked away from him
i've seen some of the craziest stuff
i've ever seen in my life here in
hollywood
jamie what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
man there's so many
keep a good network
that's probably the most important thing
i could tell somebody
because you can't do it alone
definitely can't do it alone
all right jamie thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you i wish you
the best of luck out there thank you
you